HENRY CUELLAR LIVES AND BREATHES
THIS AND IT’S MORE IMPORTANT
THAN PARTY AND POLITICS, IT’S
ABOUT THE PEOPLE HE REPRESENTS.
HOW BAD IS IT CONGRESSMAN IN
CONGRESSMAN, LOOK, I’VE SEEN THE
2014 SURGE AND 2019 SURGE AND
NOW THE ’21.
USUALLY YOU HAVE HIGH PEAKS,
MARCH, APRIL, MAY AND JUNE AND
NOW JULY GOING INTO AUGUST AND
WE ARE NOT SEEING THIS STOP.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO PUT
ATTENTION, FIRST OF ALL TO OUR
BORDER COMMUNITIES, PRIORITIZE
THE BORDER COMMUNITIES AND ALSO
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT MEN AND
WOMEN THAT ARE DOING THIS WORK.
THEY DON’T WANT JUST A PAT IN
THE BACK, THEY NEED SUPPORT,
THEY NEED EQUIPMENT, THEY NEED
PERSONNEL AND WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE’S THIS
SERIOUS SITUATION DOWN THERE AT
THE BORDER.
BRIAN: WE KNOW THAT THE
VACCINES, THEY ARE NOT PREVALENT
AND CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA
AND TOP 10 COUNTRIES WHERE THESE
PEOPLE ARE COMING FROM SO THEY
ARE COMING OVER HERE, EXCELLENT
CHANCE THEY WILL BE SPREADING
THE VIRUS.
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION REALIZE
THIS, THERE’S NO TESTING GOING
ON?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I DON’T KNOW
THE ADMINISTRATION KNOWS IT BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE MEN AND
WOMEN ON THE GROUND, YOU KNOW,
BORDER PATROL OR EVEN CUSTOMS,
THEY UNDERSTAND BECAUSE, LOOK,
IN THE VALLEY, THERE WERE 70
AGENTS THAT HAVE TESTED POSITIVE
IN THE LAREDO AREA ANOTHER 15,
NOT ONLY THE AGENTS BUT ALSO
FAMILIES WHEN THEY GO HOME, SO
WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE OUR MEN
AND WOMEN OF HOMELAND AND WE
HAVE TO PRIORITIZE DEFINITELY
THE BORDER COMMUNITIES.
I HAD, FOR EXAMPLE, I’VE HAD
COUNTY JUDGE RICHARD CORTEZ, A
DEMOCRAT IN HIDALGO WHERE ALL OF
THIS IS HAPPENING.
HE CALLED ME YESTERDAY AND SAID,
WE HAVE TO PUT A PAUSE IN ABOUT
AN HOUR OR SO LA JOYA WE ARE
HAVING THE PHONE CALL.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED, THEY
RELEASED PEOPLE IN A HOTEL BUT
NOBODY WATCHES THEM.
THERE WERE SOME OF THEM THAT
WERE SICK, POSITIVE WALKING
AROUND AND NOBODY TOLD THEM THAT
THEY GOT RELEASED IN LA JOYA,
THAT IS PART OF MY COMMUNITY AND
I WANT TO TALK TO THOSE
OFFICIALS IN ABOUT AN HOUR OR
SO.
BRIAN: CONGRESSMAN, IF THE
ADMINISTRATION LISTENED TO YOU
THEY CAN FIX THE PROBLEM.
TURN PEOPLE AWAY, SEND MESSAGE
TO CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA,
YOU SEE THE TOP 10 COUNTRIES
WHERE THEY ARE COMING FROM.
THIS HAS STOPPED BEFORE, HOW
COME YOU THEY DON’T LISTEN TO
YOU, YOU’RE A DEMOCRAT WITH A
BORDER COMMUNITY AS YOUR
CONSTITUENCY?
>> AGAIN, THEY DON’T HAVE TO
LISTEN TO ME.
THEY NEED TO LISTEN TO THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES AND THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES ARE SAYING,
HOLD UP, PUT A PAUSE.
MY HOMETOWN OF LAREDO, THEY
FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAYING, WE
DON’T WANT ANYMORE MORE BUSES OF
MIGRANTS COMING IN.
THE COUNTY JUDGE IN WEB COUNTY
PUT A DECLARATION SAYING WE ARE
GOING TO STOP BORDER PATROL
BUSES FROM BRINGING IN ANY MORE
MIGRANTS INTO THIS BECAUSE CASES
HAVE SHOT UP AND HOSPITALS ARE
GETTING FULL.
WE DON’T HAVE THE PERSONNEL TO
WORK AT THE HOSPITALS BECAUSE A
LOT OF THEM HAVE BEEN SICK.
SO THIS IS WHAT WE ARE FACING.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO LISTEN TO ME,
BUT THEY NEED TO LISTEN TO THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES, TO THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES AND THEY
CERTAINLY NEED TO LISTEN TO THE
MEN AND WOMEN.
THEY DON’T JUST WANT A PAT IN
THE BACK, THEY NEED SOME REAL
HELP NOW.
BRIAN: AND WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC
AND THEY TOLD US THE MIGRANTS
WERE GOING TO STOP BECAUSE IT’S
SO HOT AND THEY ARE STILL
COMING.
CONGRESSMAN CUELLAR, YOU CARE
ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE MORE
THAN PARTY AND IT’S SO RARE
TODAY.
I HOPE PEOPLE START LISTENING TO